today we're talking about serverless
spark limitless data baseball and
enterprise learning i'm terry and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
earlier this year we made serverless
spark generally available creating the
industry's first auto scaling serverless
spark and now we're taking it a step
further and making serverless spark even
more powerful by enabling serverless
interactive development through jupyter
notebooks natively integrated with
vertex ai workbench now a data scientist
will not need to provision any
infrastructure in advance they can just
start developing on demand
with the dramatic growth in the amount
and types of data workloads and users we
are at a point where traditional data
architectures even when deployed in the
cloud are unable to unlock its full
potential
as a result the data value gap is
growing to address these challenges
we're unveiling several data cloud
innovations that allow customers to work
with limitless data across all workloads
and extend access to everyone from big
lake and spanner change streams to
vertex ai workbench and model registry
check out the blog for more
baseball and statistics go way back
these days cloud technology enables mlb
to collect and analyze 25 million unique
data points from each of its 2430
regular season games
from helping players improve their
performance to bringing fans closer to
the action we'll walk you through a few
ways mlb is hitting a grand slam with
data
there are countless reasons why
enterprises are moving to the cloud from
reduced i.t costs to improve security
and efficiency but how will
organizations accelerate cloud adoption
within their organizations
the answer is comprehensive training
google cloud skills boost combines
award-winning learning experiences with
the ability to earn credentials to
validate learning which can be managed
and delivered directly by google cloud
with enterprise level features
learn more about our research driven
courses and how you can get started on
the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud